d'abord le portrait de celle qui va
devenir la 25e à locataire de matignon
avec mathias arese
après les transports la transition
écologique et finalement le travail
c'est à matignon qu'elisabeth bornes va
poursuivre sa collaboration avec
emmanuel macron ministre depuis 2010 est
l'ancienne présidente de la ratp était
annoncée comme favorite pour succéder à
jean castex depuis plusieurs semaines
devrais je vous appelle madame la
première ministre madame le premier
ministre dans les prochains jours je
crois que c'est pas le sujet vous savez
je pense que ce qui est important c'est
d'entendre le message des français leurs
inquiétudes sur le pouvoir d'achat leurs
attentes sur l'écologie et j'ai pas de
doute qu emmanuel macron tour à l'équipe
pour mener ce projet mais si on vous
confie une telle responsabilité vous
pouvez pas dire non enfin je vous dis
c'est pas la question je pense que ce
qui est important c'est qu'on puisse
mettre en oeuvre le projet qui a été
porté par emmanuel macron question le
président de la république avait annoncé
vouloir un profil social écologique et
productif selon ses propres mots pour
les observateurs elisabeth bornes koch
toutes les cases préfète directrice de
cabinet de ségolène royal un parcours
plus techno - politique un bon point
pour l'ancien ministre issu de la jambe
gauche de la majorité dernier critère de
recrutement pour la nouvelle locataire
de matignon sa capacité à gérer les
grandes réformes voulues par emmanuel
macron avec en tête de gondole les
retraites là encore les réformes de la
sncf et de l'assurance chômage elle
plaide pour elisabeth bornes investi
pour les législatives dans le calvados
la haute fonctionnaire soumettra par
ailleurs pour la première fois sa
candidature au suffrage à 61 ans la
native de paris devient donc la deuxième
femme a prédit cresson a posé ses
valises de varennes
bienvenue dans l'enfer de matignon voilà
comment on a décidé de titrer ce premier
débat dans ce sens public avec ariane a
même dit bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
sensé iran en communication chez only
conseil bérengère bonté bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi journaliste et
auteur de le sioux ce portrait des
douars philips est publié aux éditions
de l'archipel bruno cautrès politologue
bruno bienvenue à vous aussi chercheur
au cnrs et au cevipof et matthieu
croissandeau éditorialiste politique
bienvenus
mathieu on a envie de dire enfin parce
que c'est quand même trois semaines
qu'on attend la nomination
à ce poste de premier ministre alors
encore une fois à l'heure où nous
prenons l'antenne ce n'est pas encore
officiel mais ça ne saurait tarder
puisque bérengère bonté elle est en ce
moment dans le bureau du président
république à l'elysée voilà quatre ans
jean castex il a passé une petite heure
je crois et puis ça s'est enchaîné très
vite finalement après cette longue
attente la sacem là ça a été rapide et
elle est dans le bureau effectivement du
président de la république on va dire
qu'il a pu beaucoup de suspense la
vérité
rien à me disent et c'est on l'a dit la
première femme à matignon depuis edith
cresson mais est-ce que cet élément là
qui est un élément important je pense
que c'est pas le plus important même
s'il faut l'analyser il ya beaucoup
d'autres qualités que
simplement le fait d'être une femme qui
préside à cette nomination j'en suis
convaincue mais est ce que c'est gommer
cet effet-là par le manque de nouveauté
parce que lisa baseband finalement était
déjà au gouvernement leur poste on l'a
vu trois choses pour répondre à deux
questions la première chose c'est que
personne commente beaucoup les mots que
les commentateurs utilisent on a
beaucoup parlé de casting donc on est
dans une dynamique aujourd'hui on parle
de casting si les gens au congo au
cinéma qu'on parle d'un directeur de
casting qu'est ce qu'ils cherchent une
énergie en profil qui répond sans savoir
exactement on n'a pas besoin de savoir
qui va bien lire le texte il faut qu'il
réponde aux jobs donc ça c'est la
première partie de ma réponse sur les
questions de la femme c'est l'idée
d'avoir quelqu'un qui répond à un moment
donné ce qu'attend l'opinion ce qu
attendre l opinion publique en termes de
tendance quelque chose deuxième chose
vous me parlez de l'effet nouveauté je
pense que emmanuel macron a fait la
start up datsun en 2017 ça c'était le
premier le truc un peu transgressif et
c'est aujourd'hui pour avoir un effet
nouveauté effectivement le fait de
mettre une femme qui est quand même
historique en tant que tel enfin et du
cresson est passée par là mais elle est
passée le trait de façon très bref quand
même et tout le monde sait quand même
même si les choses évoluent et cetera
que le monde de la politique a fortiori
du ps du premier ministre qui est un
monde qui a un thème un job de
ressources humaines aussi un cri de
gérer des ministres au dessous au
dessous de vous c'est quand même assez
effectivement je trouve qu'il ya quelque
chose d'assez intéressant dans le fait
de mettre une femme gestionnaire
technocratique mais aussi de gérer des
gens avec des égos aussi qu'ils sont
importants alors il faudra évidemment
jugées sûres sur pièce à bruno cautrès
alors on vous parlait avait
effectivement du casting et c est ce qu
on peut dire qu'elle cochet presque
toutes les cases et il avait dû vendre
c'est intéressant parce que la première
chose qu'on se félicite avec mathieu
quand il est arrivé tout à l'heure on
peut le dire aux s'est dit un peu tout
ça pour ça parce que c'est le premier
nom qui était sorti il ya trois semaines
voyez ce que je veux dire dans quelques
os objectivement pas mal de casamance et
qu'elle devait quand même que j'ai pas
mal de casse si son nom avait été
rapidement sorti si tout au long de
cette longue chronique des ces trois
dernières semaines avec toutes les
supputations toutes les hypothèses qui
ont été été présenté son nom était quand
même toujours présent elle n'a jamais
son nom n'a jamais été au fond à un
moment donné on n'a jamais dit
maintenant finalement elle est sortie du
lait sortie du du cadre donc son nom a
toujours été cité son nom a toujours été
cités quand même parmi les personnalités
favorites pour être nommé premier
ministre donc c'est vrai quelques jeux
beaucoup de cas je pense qu'il ya une
case qui est très importante et qui
explique peut-être aussi ça sa
nomination emmanuel macron deuxième
mandat deuxième mandat où ils nous
expliquent qu'ils ne va pas faire la
même chose que le premier mandat donc si
on veut un élément quand même de
continuité un moment donné il faut
peut-être quelqu'un qui était déjà dans
l'équipe on imagine que les membres du
gouvernement issu de la matrice de
départ d' emmanuel macron ceux qui vont
rester ça sera plus simple pour eux de
travailler avec une ministre qu'ils
connaissent déjà première mise qu'ils
connaissent déjà très bien que si on
leur avait dit de demander d'une
certaine manière de se redéfinir avec un
chef d'état qui dit moi je passe
travaille de la même manière je veux
incarner quelque chose de deux nouveaux
dont je pense aussi cet élément de
continuité dans un moment de l'opinion
publique est un moment qui est toujours
quand même avec plein de points
d'interrogation en pleine inquiétude
élection présidentielle n'a pas n'a pas
réglé l'allèle la crise d'angoissé
sociale française et donc de ce point de
vue là je trouve qu'elle correspond pas
mal effectivement à ce moment mathieu
oui le présent la république avait
dressé une forme de portrait-robot vous
souvenez en disant qu'il fallait que ce
soit quelqu'un qui soit attaché à la
question environnementale à la mission
sociale et la question productive en ce
monde un peu ce que ça voulait dire et
puis fallait que ce soit une femme de ce
point de vue là tout le monde avait
pensé à l'époque et même avant elisabeth
bande parce qu'elles remplissent et
c'est une femme bien évidemment elle est
attachée à la question sociale ça reste
ça reste à vérifier mais elle a géré des
dossiers sociaux compliqué elle a fait
la réforme de la sncf elle a fait elle a
poursuivi la réforme du chômage et on se
connaît les anges où j'avais été
président de la ratp comment maîtriser
un peu les syndicats mais l'année elle
connaît l'environnement pour avoir été
même si son bilan n'est pas
extraordinaire elle a été ministre de la
transition écologique a été directrice
de cabinet il faut le rappeler de
ségolène royal elle-même ministre de
l'écologie et puis la question
productive on peut résumer en disant que
c'est quelqu'un qui a eu un parcours en
entreprise c'est vrai qu'elle a
travaillé non seulement elle a été
directrice de la stratégie la sncf elle
a été à ratp par la suite elle a
travaillé au groupe eiffage bref c'est
quelqu'un qui a une vie professionnelle
un vrai parcours de serviteurs de l'état
on va dire elle a démarré savait qu'elle
est ingénieur polytechnicien n'a pas
fait l'ena elle a démarré dans les
cabinets ministériels auprès de lionel
jospin dès le début des années 90 puis
jack lang puis de nouveau lionel jospin
quand il était premier ministre qu'elle
connaît parfaitement l'appareil d'état
est là était préfète elle remplit à peu
près toutes ces cases là c'est quand
même déjà énorme ensuite la vraie
interrogation ses excuses il ya un sens
est ce qu'un signal politique qui a
envoyé avec la nomination des maîtres
board pas tant que ça parce qu'on a beau
dire que c'est une femme qui a grandi
dans les cabinets de gauche et qu'elle
était proche du parti socialiste et pas
quelqu'un qui a un passé d'élu non l
histoire de
la personne connue qui
regroupe les le gauche dite de la
majorité mais que personne ne connaît
donc c'est pas vraiment ça et est-ce que
souligné bruno est très important c'est
tfc c'est quelqu'un avec qui emmanuel
macron va pouvoir travailler en
confiance sans surprise d'une certaine
façon ce n'était pas le cas d'edouard
philippe les terres un nouveau venu ce
qui n'était pas le cas de jean castex
avec qui la met un peu travaillé sur le
déconfinement et les jo mais pas tant
que ça elisabeth borrel le connais
depuis longtemps elle connaît notamment
très bien alexis colère qui était quand
elle était ministre
idriss kameni voit la directrice de
cabinet pardon de ségolène royal alexis
colère était directeur de cabinet des
manuels macron à bercy et ils ont
commencé à travailler ensemble à se
connaître si donc ces c'est quelqu'un de
confiance et puis c'est pas quelqu'un
non plus qu a une envergure politique
exceptionnel mais ce qui la sert parce
que d'une certaine façon et on ne
manquerait pas nommer quelqu'un qui peut
lui faire une forme d'onde donc le
profil et dans le casting par le casting
est plutôt pas si mal mais je suis
d'accord avec vous ce n'est pas faire
injure à l'eysée bornes de dire que
c'est pas la plus charismatique
du personnel politique actuelle c'est
aussi une case quelques hommes quand
c'est aussi une case quelques os qui s'y
était dit de jean castex et vous avez
raison probablement qu'il fallait pas
une superstar unis et on l'a souvent
souligné qu'ils feraient sans doute un
peu trop d'ombré moi je suis je suis
toujours assez prudent sur ces histoires
de cocher des cases en fait je trouve si
on prend que la case environnementale
par exemple elle a été un an ministre de
la transition écologique vous en parler
avec les acteurs les ong etc ils lui
font pas procès d'intention parce que
mais c'est surtout qu'elle apparaît là
ni le temps ni eu les mains libres pour
le faire vous regardez le bilan est
arrivé il y avait une loi de transition
écologique était déjà passé que françois
de rugy avait déjà fait adopter et puis
très vite il ya ulcos vide donc elle
s'est occupée alors oui elle a un peu
facilité par exemple le plan vélo voilà
ce serait toute petite chose la vraie
question c'est de savoir le le périmètre
qu'elle aura réellement et la volonté
réelle du président de la république
d'engager cette transition écologique
sinon ça ne sert à rien de
connu il ya une loi qui a été votée
quand elle était au ministère de
l'écologie la loi hajek
anti dies puis pour une économie
circulaire qui a beaucoup de
conséquences pour les entreprises et qui
permet à des filières de secret voilà je
dis ça c'est pas le plus important c'est
un peu passé sous les radars mais c'est
une loi importante contacts mais pas ce
que je veux dire c'est qu'on ne voit pas
bien qui l'a quelle est la vision en
augmentation on est d'accord de
techniques énormément et tout ça c'est à
son crédit regarde moi une chambre qui a
quand même quelque chose très important
aussi on parle d du rapport aux 110 cas
on parle de en fait de deux ministères
qui sont des ministères de la transition
en réalité en fait aujourd'hui le vrai
sujet c'est la question de la gestion
des transitions notamment pour les plus
modestes et qu'est ce que ça veut dire
derrière tout ça on parle de la question
de la gestion aussi du rapport de force
et ça je trouve que c'est intéressant
aussi parce que il ya l'idée de est ce
qu'on peut et ça c'est elisabeth borne à
voir est technocratique et gérer un
rapport de force qui est en fait la
façon on va dire plus cordiales de dire
la politique et ça je trouve que c'est
intéressant comme question posée en
termes purement d'avec ma casquette de
communicante qui est le gestionnaire
peut-il être un bon gestionnaire du
rapport de forces est ça l a vraiment de
quoi faire si jamais c'est effectivement
vraiment ces périmètres la à la hauteur
de ces enjeux là ce sera intéressant je
disais tout à l'heure bienvenue dans
l'enfer de matignon mais est-ce que
c'est toujours vrai tient bruno cautrès
parce que avec le passage au quinquennat
ça quand même un peu changé le la donne
l'équilibré des pouvoirs au sein du duo
de l'exécutif jean castex a dit qu'il ne
s'était pas senti en ferries et qui
n'avait pas senti les flammes de l'enfer
c'est vrai qu'il a eu la période de kovy
quand même très très difficilement quand
même beaucoup d'anciens premiers
ministres et leurs témoignages mettant
son a quand même assez récurrent
décrivent effectivement une machine à
rabat a broyé à finir effectivement
absolument laminé et puis à l'enfer
aussi d'animer la majorité effectivement
il ya la dimension de ressources
humaines de gestionnaire et moi c'est
une des interrogations que me posent la
nomination d'elizabeth doit mener qui
est extrêmement intéressante c'est de
dire au fond comment va-t-elle se muter
en premier ministre est non seulement un
animateur de l'équipe mais le premier
ministre il doit également et incarner
une forme de l'autorité l'autorité de
l'état c'est quand même lui qui est le
patron de l'état c'est ce que dit la
constitution il est celui qui conduit la
politique de la delà de la nation donc
ça doit être quelqu'un qui sait faire
tourner la machine de l'état de ce point
de vue là son curriculum vitae par le
pot n ya aucun souci est là de ce point
de vue là
aussi
elle sait faire mais au niveau de
devenir un premier ministre c'est-à-dire
quelqu'un qui en situation de crise et
c'est vrai que nous avons depuis
quelques années une série de crises
majeures j'espère qu'on n'aura pas
d'autres mais qui c'est qui
effectivement a le sens du commandement
comme a pu la voir jean castex lorsqu'il
prend ses responsabilités et qui fait
tourner la machine au fond à ce que la
gestion du coc vide soit enfin efficace
et encore plus efficace que ne l'était
qu'elle ne l'était avant et donc cette
dimension est une dimension dans
laquelle elle va devoir s'affirmer assez
assez rapidement il ya aussi
le fait qu'elle soit candidate aux
législatives dans le calvados à vire en
à regarder les scores des manuels macron
alors évidemment on s'est compliqué non
pas une présence yen à lys lez steve
c'est pas c'est pas du copier coller
mais c'est intéressant de le regarder il
est fait 35% au premier tour 59 % au
second tour bérengère bonté encore
faut-il qu'elles gagnent hollis l'atvs
ces essais je pense qu'elle peut être on
va dire poussé par sa nomination à
matignon ça devrait l'aider mais c'est
quand même un cas de figure regarder
dans un coin de la tête et par un peu
probable mais évidemment souvenez-vous
d'alain juppé qui était numéro deux du
gouvernement de nicolas sarkozy mais ça
a duré six semaines et puis on voir quoi
alors on va voir s'il ya une demande ça
paraît inconcevable de rester à matignon
si on perd je veillerai genre de
sélection donc donc c'est surtout à
cette faute il ya une liaison sur ya une
prise de risque certaines oui d'autant
qu'elle va devoir mener aussi la
campagne des législatives pour
poursuivre ce que disait bruno c'est
vrai qu'il faut qu'on sache faire preuve
de sens politique et de leadership ça
c'est sûr même si il faut le dire quand
même dans le jeu des institutions
aujourd'hui est telle que les pratiques
emmanuel macron tout se décide quand
même beaucoup à l'elysée et le le
locataire de matignon est plutôt
quelqu'un qui met en musique c'est pour
ça que ça va frotter un peu avec edouard
philippe qui au bout d'un moment a voulu
assumer des positions parfois différente
de l'autre tête de l'exécutif ce qui ne
fut pas du tout le cas de jean castex
qui a mis en musique absolument tout ce
que emmanuel macron lui demandait avec
une certaine abnégation un certain
talent puisqu'il a fait ce que l'autre
lui a demandé mais mme elisabeth borne
n'a pas se retrouver dans une situation
différente parce que la majorité va être
plus compliqué à gérer et je ne parle
pas du score que la majorité fera aux
législatives mais de son caractère
composite cette majorité avec des
ambitions qui vont être puisqu'on est
dans le dernier quinquennat d'emmanuel
macron et que très vite nous devons
penser à la suite il va falloir
permettre à tous on a d'exister de faire
entendre sa voix tout en assurant une
forme de cohésion et avec des votes
solidaire pour les très grands textes ça
risque d'être assez compliqué je reviens
sur le fait que ce soit une femme nommée
à matignon on attend encore la
confirmation de l' agence france-presse
à l'heure où je vous parle mais bon
encore une fois on est on se permet
d'être affirmatif et magma quand il va
dans le sens de des trois quarts des
français 74% des français favorables à
la nomination d'une première ministre
sondage ifop pour le jdd journal du
dimanche hier est ce que c'est aussi
rien à hamdi un message aux électeurs de
gauche finalement ce choix là d'après
vous alors ça peut être un message
de féministes plus par rapport à la
promesse de but premier quinquennat de
les femmes enfin la grande cause du
quinquennat je suis pas sûr que pour moi
la plus grande promesse aux électeurs
sociaux démocrates c'est plutôt de
présenter les sujets écologie france que
j'ai appelé transition mais on peut le
dire autrement mais écologie mobilité
travail en fait c'est l'idée que il a
laissé en fait si vous voulez c'est la
stratégie de lange en deux manches la
nouvelle stratégie que tout le monde
fait mélenchon ou en gros second tour il
dit rendez vous aux législatives pour
médire premier ministre emmanuel macron
de façon assez maligne laisse les gens
se battre comme il l'a fait pour la
présidentielle donc ce qui fait que
effectivement comme celle des nouveaux
mouvements pas des nouveaux mouvements
et des nouvelles alliances ça commence à
se fissurer assez vite pour x ou y
raison hélas pour moi comme il l'a fait
en europe en disant je révise les
traités etc il commence à prendre avec
les y en ait d'autres à présenter des
sujets sociaux démocrates pour fissurer
encore plus à gauche mais sur cette
question quand même deux
la place d'une femme à matignon j'y
reviens c'est c'est pas le plus
important mais c'est important il ya
cinq pays de l'union européenne
aujourd'hui qui sont dirigées par des
femmes le danemark la finlande la
lituanie la suède et l'estonie puis
surtout donc on va voir cette première
information la liste de ces pays et puis
alors surtout moi ce qui me frappe c'est
que en europe les les deux tiers des
pays de l'union européenne ont déjà été
dirigées par des femmes mathieu je
rappelle qu'il faut remonter plus de
trois décennies en arrière pour avoir
pour retrouver à edith cresson à
matignon avec un éphémère passage à
matignon il faut il faut s'en souvenir
puisqu'elle restera tout juste moins en
moins d'un an et il faut se souvenir de
la difficulté qu'a eue a dit cresson à
s'imposer sur la scène politique alors
même qu on oublie souvent c'était une
femme politique c'était une vraie femme
politique et lectrices ont un membre de
la convention des institutions
républicaines avec mitterrand 64 avant
l'agression du ps nombre lors de la
création du parti socialiste quant à
elle arrivée à matignon elle a été
quatre fois minutes enfin il a été maire
député député européenne ministres de
l'agriculture du commerce extérieur des
affaires européennes donc c'est
quelqu'un qui a un très solide parcours
politique et elle arrive alors il ya
autre chose qu'on oublie parfois drapé
c'est qu'elle arrive dans le pire
contexte ce saut socio économique qu'ait
connu la france pour un premier ministre
elle le dira elle même à l'époque
puisque on atteint le plafond quasiment
du chômage de masse des années
mitterrand c'est l'horreur c'est la fin
de la gauche au pouvoir et et ont pu y
91 points quasiment au jour près
d'ailleurs c'était le 15 mai 81 et elle
arrive dans un donc dans ce contexte
très difficile avec un style qui va
détonner parce que elle a parfois des
expressions dit je me souviens la bourse
j'en ai rien à cirer au téléphone à
un journaliste allait voilà elle a ce
côté là et qui lui vaut très vite 2 du 2
du fait qu'elle a été placé là par
françois mitterrand elle est considérée
comme sa chose certaine façon il ya des
caricaturistes vous souvenez du bébête
show qu'il faut une marionnette à son
effigie qui le baptise à ma botte vous
voyez un peu le niveau des attaques
sexistes et elle a un conseiller dans
son dans son cabinet qui s'appelle abel
farnoux qu'on soupçonne tout de suite de
tirer les ficelles et qu'on surnomme le
marionnettiste comme si une femme ne
pouvait pas avoir sa propre indépendance
de jugement et puis c'est vrai qu'elle
est quand même non seulement victime d'
attaques sexistes et puis de choses que
s'est permise par exemple françois
mitterrand g ce pas le souvenir qu'il
l'ait fait par exemple il lui fait
réécrire son discours de politique
générale parce que il considère que le
texte est pas bon et lui dit prenez
plutôt celui-là ça sera mieux voilà elle
a du mal à imposer à imposer ses choix
et sa politique parce qu'elle est tout
le temps remise en cause et il ya des
phrases on s'en souvient de mémoire est
traité de poissonnière part je crois
ont pas ou bien entendu c'est sa vraie
voilà tout y passe ont besoin dit elle
le raconte dans le journal du dimanche
hier que l a une cicatrice à la jambe et
on se permet de commenter en disant que
c'est bas son filet voilà deux niveaux
des attaques sexistes sur son nous sur
sa personnalité et sur sa politique
aussi parce que elle mène des choix qui
déplaisent aussi français bérengère
bonté l'époque a changé on peut espérer
que il avait d'abord de supplier de ne
subira pas ce qui est dit de crise on a
subi on peut l'espérer très cintrée de
moins affirmatif que moi ouais moi je
vraiment et pourtant je crois vraiment
que ce serait important qu'elle
réussisse à dire il ya où il ya eu
énormément d'études qui ont été faites
sur la question de savoir pourquoi tout
le monde veut une femme matignon à
l'elysée mais personne mais globalement
on ne voit pas pour une femme et et
c'est pas le seul facteur bien entendu
mais mais toutes les toutes les études
qui ont été faits de là dessus montre
quand même que il ya ce petit procès en
illégitimité il vient du fait que on
n'en voit pas au perchoir des femmes
depuis toujours on n'en voit pas la tête
du sénat on n'envoie pas à matignon on
n'en voit pas au cee et voilà on ne voit
pas en fonction et donc au moment de
mettre son bulletin de vote on si on les
voit pas trop on sait pas s'il ya une
petite musique comme ça qui est qui qui
qui retient le bras de l'électeur et
dans certains cas enfin tout cas le fait
est que il ya eu plusieurs fois trois
fois des fils une femme ou ségolène
royal marine le pen en finale de la
présidentielle et que c'est pas si
jamais aller au bout et que globalement
les candidats te font rarement des gros
score aux présidentielles voilà 18h21 on
vient d'avoir le l'officialisation sur
le site de l'elysée il avait deux bornes
et effectivement nommé premier ministre
et d'ailleurs il va falloir que con
qu'on attende peut-être ce que sa
décision commence ou et celle qu'on la
présente une dérive le premier ministre
s est madame la première ministre voilà
ça c'est reparti du petit solutions qui
sont pas touchés le mari disait qu'il
souhaitait qu'on appelle même le
ministre par exemple oui et avant ça
oui bon bah ça fera partie des petites
questions à suivre vous direz oui je
voulais leur dire en vous écoutant je
suis complètement d'accord mais je me
disais en fait parce que moi dans ma
pratique de média training et de même si
des femmes et des jeunes femmes parce
qu'il ya aussi une génération qui arrive
en politique hommes et femmes d'ailleurs
et j'essaie de travailler je veux dire
déjà en me renseignant enfin - en
travaillant pour ce que c'est mieux
travailler pour vous conseiller et puis
les gens sur c'est quoi l'autorité la
puissance au féminin parce que quand je
ne vous écoutait je me disais quelque
chose et en il ya des choses très
intéressantes qui sont dites là dessus
sur la puissance se dire politique au
féminin en fait les hommes politiques
beaucoup l'habitude en radio en télé
d'antan
leur puissance vient du fait qu'il n'ya
pas d'auto-censure sur le fait de
manipuler un auditoire avec de l'affect
c'est non mais c'est très intéressant
une femme qui ferait la même chose qu'on
appelle la séduction au sens je veux
dire plus basile du terme qui est le
propre de la politique s'en est donc une
femme quand elle doit profiter de la
faiblesse et la projeter de la voix et
manipuler un auditoire ce que font les
actrices par exemple une actrice elle a
un rôle mais elle le fait avec un rôle
autour de la notion d'autorité ou spa je
vois moi je me suis témoin en training
que c'est beaucoup plus compliqué et je
pense qu'il ya vraiment une réflexion
sur le coup sûr à faire sur la question
de l'émotion et de comment les femmes
politiques notamment elisabeth band ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'elle a
quelque chose de très rigoureux c'est ça
un profil on va dire l'x et c'est très
rigoureux et quand elle va être au
perchoir comme vous dites comme vous
dites comment elle va faire le perchoir
c'est quand on est président de
l'assemblée
comment elle va faire pour effectivement
gérer là et ça va être de l'autorité au
sens vraiment émotionnelles terme des
gens qui vont être vraiment crier etc ça
chauffe ça va vraiment passionnant alors
la prochaine étape on va beaucoup par
les dents dans la seconde partie de ce
débat bruno cautrès mais c'est assez
intéressant c'est la formation du
gouvernement c'est aussi le discours de
politique générale alors là on va
peut-être entendre d'ici à la fin de
cette émission la passation de pouvoir y
aura une première prise de parole
d'elisabeth board premier ou premier
ministre on verra comment elle souhaite
le le dire mais le discours de politique
générale c'est un moment évidemment
constitutifs de l'eau justement d'un
bruit ce un moment absolument centrale
puisque c'est la feuille de route que
comme ministre ou la première ministre
présente à la majorité à l'opposition ou
français de manière plus générale et
c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose qui
le suit tout au long de son de son
mandat et on peut régulièrement
d'ailleurs quand on suit le calendrier
de l'action gouvernementale on peut
régulièrement se référer à ce texte pour
voir où est ce qu'on en est puisque
normalement c'est à ce moment là que le
premier ministre ou la première miss
fixe ses priorités donne parfois aussi
des des éléments de calendrier un peu d
comment on commence à avoir des éléments
de chiffrage il faut pas oublier non
plus l'autre étape très importante qu'il
qu'il attend dans les semaines qui
arrivent le projet de loi de finances
qui sera discuté cet automne et qui lui
va nous en dire assez long sur la mise
en oeuvre du projet d' emmanuel macron
les priorités soit l'écologie sur
l'hôpital sur l'école la question
épineuse qui va ne pas manquer d'arriver
à un moment donné qui va être celle des
déficits publics l'inflation est là elle
augmente les taux de remboursement de la
dette française avec des décisions sans
douloureuse qui vont devoir être prise
assez rapidement et donc effectivement
de ce point de vue là on va rencontrer
7,7 cette question qui est quel type
d'autorité elle va arriver a affirmé
comment elle va imposer son autorité est
ce que ça va être plutôt une autorité d
expertise quelqu'un qui a une très
grosse expérience est très forte
expérience
des dossiers techniques de la machine de
l'état donc 1
un leadership et une autorité plus sur
la compétence ou est ce qu'elle va
arriver à se muter en personnalité
politique c'est-à-dire qui arrive à
afficher une personnalité et qui quelque
part fait naître elisabeth ben non plus
simplement comme ministère que nous la
connaissons mais comme un personnage
avec sa particularité comme edouard
philippe lorsqu'il est nommé et très peu
connu des français devient edouard
philippe progressivement jean castex
exact exactement la même chose il a su
imposer un style donc quel style à elle
elle va choisir de dans quel répertoire
elle va jouer alors on va se concentrer
maintenant sur l' équilibre du duo de
l'exécutif et je propose un style
jourdain ii de nous rejoindre bonsoir
steve bienvenue à vous pour répondre à
cette question toute simple à quoi sert
un premier ministre dans la constitution
à gouverner un premier mini sas à
gouverner c'est ce que la question de la
constitution déclare déclare à
l'intérieur de la constitution le chef
du gouvernement est celui qui détermine
et conduit la politique de la nation
c'est l'article 20 de la constitution ça
c'est évidemment la théorie en pratique
évidemment hors cohabitation a
l'impression que toutes les décisions
sont prises à l'elysée nicolas sarkozy
on s'en rappelle l'écrivain françois
fillon comme un simple collaborateur et
c'est un peu normal un finalement
puisque le premier ministre doit
beaucoup au président article 8 de la
constitution le président de la
république nomme le premier ministre et
nous paraît évident comme ça mais en
allemagne par exemple le président
propose un premier ministre ce sont les
députés qui votent pour confirmer ou ne
pas confirmer le chancelier en france on
avoue le détacher un le premier ministre
du parlement ça fait qu'on peut être
premier ministre sans être un
parlementaire exemple georges pompidou
exemple jean castex exemple et il avait
de bord mais est ce que ça veut dire que
selon la constitution le promu nice ne
peut rien décider lui-même alors il ya
des pouvoirs propres au premier ministre
allait pouvoir partager entre le premier
ministre et le président en matière de
pouvoirs propres et si l'on s'en tient à
la théorie le président et le simple
arbitre du bon fonctionnement des
institutions alors que de son côté bien
le gouvernement lui détermine donc la
politique de la nation en pratique le
premier ministre applique le programme
de la majorité parlement alors que cette
majorité soit de la même couleur
politique le président ou pas s'il ya
cohabitation est bien le premier
ministre fera passer des réformes qui ne
sont pas nécessairement approuvée par le
président c'est ce qui s'était passé
dans les années 80 entre chirac et
mitterrand au sujet notamment des
privatisations
mais même quand ya pas de cohabitation
ils peuvent parfois se marcher sur les
pieds oui encore une fois si l'on s'en
tient à la constitution le premier
ministre partage certains pouvoirs avec
le président par exemple en matière de
relations internationales le texte ce
nous dit bien que le gouvernement
dispose de la force armée et que le
premier ministre est responsable de la
défense nationale de son côté le
président est défini comme le garant de
l'indépendance nationale de l'intégrité
du territoire et du respect des traités
il accrédite les ambassadeurs il est le
chef des armées si l'article 15 mons a
encore une fois c'est la théorie en
pratique c'est clairement le chef de
l'état qui représente la france à
l'international et en matière de
relations internationales
il y est en général peu ou pas du tout
de divergences de vues entre président
et premier ministre même en période de
cohabitation ça pourrait changer ça
pourrait changer notamment si jean luc
mélenchon donné le premier ministre
d'emmanuel macron le mois prochain on
suivra sa merci beaucoup steve a tout à
l'heure dans notre second débat bon
l'hypothèse jean luc mélenchon on y
reviendra et on a encore un bon mois de
campagne avant le premier tour mais
quand même sur cet équilibre du duo de
l'exécutif bérengère bon vous l'avez
étudié forcément pour le portrait de
d'edouard philippe que vous avez publié
le sioux aux éditions de l'archipel il
ya plusieurs étapes dans le
fonctionnement de ceux de ce duo macron
philippe il ya de toute façon dans ce
duo là
un duo que j'ai aussi étudié pendant
votre livre sur lequel j'avais travaillé
sur les conseils des ministres la vème
république et c'est cher c'est un duo
d'hommes ou de femmes qu'en l'occurrence
mais il ya deux personnes qui déjà
qu'ils doivent s'apprivoiser c'est
quelque chose qui est edouard philippe
et emmanuel macron de l'extérieur comme
ça on avait le sentiment que ça allait
marcher tout de suite ces deux
personnages qui n'ont jamais vraiment
complètement qui ne se sont jamais
vraiment trouvé donc y avait pas et
manifestement il n'y avait pas là le
l'intimité je sais pas comment dire le
clou la cohésion qui avait avec un
castex par exemple donc ça c'est la
première chose et puis ensuite il y
avait une autre contre un contexte qui
était compliquée qui était politique
quelques manuels macro arrivé avec une
majorité qui n'était pas qui est le
reflet peut-être n'était pas issu de ce
même quand donc il fallait aller là
aussi qui fasse ses preuves qu'ils se
fassent acceptée par une majorité qui
est qui qui arrivée triomphante et qui
avait gagné la présidentielle et donc à
sa troisième strate s'ajoute un
directeur de cabinet et qui est dans le
cadre de leur fille pas eu une place à
ces centrales ça a parfois été critiqué
même d'ailleurs parle par la place
qu'avait benoît ribadeau-dumas le
directeur de cabinet sur lequel edouard
philippe s'était beaucoup battue ça va
être intéressant de regarder et ça c'est
quelque chose un premier ministre qui
cède là dessus
c'est un mas et ses débuts probablement
de beaucoup de différence avec emmanuel
macron souhaitait imposer un autre celui
qui a finalement été directeur cabinet
de jean castex meilleurs voilà oui et
donc évidemment si le prénom république
impose
c'était au sein du cabinet à faire la
tête du cabinet deux fois ministre il ya
un contrôle encore plus ses rayons et
cinq ans il est le fonctionnement du duo
se met en place progressivement
effectivement alors après au gré des
crises chaque crise et chaque gestion de
crise donne lieu à une remise en place
des rôles de chacun une explication de
texte qui et puis on se rôde comme dans
n'importe quel duo ou n'importe quel
couple une fois c'est vrai qu'on est
dans un profil très différent parce que
edouard philippe avait une autonomie
politique d'une autonomie de pensée j'ai
été élu au havre député puis maire et il
avait eu tout un parcours au sein de
l'ump qu'il avait contribué d'ailleurs à
façonner et a créé un puisque c'est lui
qui avait été un des architectes de sa
nouvelle politique et puis ensuite
auprès d'alain juppé elisabeth bornel
néant politique d'une certaine façon au
visage des français et ou à la lumière
et puis et puis dans la réalité de la
pratique du pouvoir avec emmanuel macron
donc c'est un bon produit de la macro ni
d'une certaine façon ce qui n'efface pas
le parcours qu'elle a pu avoir en tant
que haute fonctionnaire et puis et puis
femme d'engagement mégère elle n'est
vraiment en politique avec avec sa macro
ni donc sacré tout de suite un rapport
il ya moins d'autres elle a une
autonomie de pensée bien entendu mais
moins d'autonomie politique que ne
l'avaient edouard philippe ça suppose
aussi une bonne entente vous le disiez à
entre le le présent la république et son
premier sa première ministre on va
s'habituer à dire ça et c'est très bien
à écouter ce qu'en disait françois
bayrou c'était hier sur rtl dans le
grand jury et dit il faut du leadership
il faut de l'expérience
et il faut
une empathie assez grande avec le
président de la république il faut pas
j'ai connu j'ai causé un jeu je vais
vous dire des choses très très simple
j'ai connu un des gouvernements
probablement les plus brillants sur le
papier
c'était mitterrand président de la
république michel rocard premier
ministre on peut pas dire que c'était
des un différend qui n'avait pas mis
leadership ni expérience mais ils se
détestaient et quand le président de la
république déteste le premier ministre
les choses ne peuvent que tournait mal
mathieu il faut qu'on soit honnête à
chaque fois qu'on entend françois bayrou
commenter la possibilité de faire
on a l'impression que c'est lui bref
mais mais mais quand même c'est une
dimension qui est intéressant de nous
contrer ce rappel historique le la
question de l'entente voilà le d'un duo
comme celui qui qui gère un pays comme
la france c'est quand même majeurs
effectivement je sais pas dans quel dans
quel sens l'inimitié entre françois
mitterrand et michel rocard était la
plus forte est ce que c'était mitterrand
qui ne supportaient pas à michel rocard
ou l' inverse mais en tout cas elle
était réel partage
c'est vrai que ce lyonnais de ce couple
exécutif français est littéralement fait
sinon je pense que tous ceux qui aiment
les institutions l'histoire des
institutions qui sont fascinés par ce
régime de la vème république
cet objet est absolument fascinant on a
constitué dans le dans le texte de notre
constitution une sorte de deux binômes
ou de dieu ont peu infernal c'est à dire
il ya deux têtes pour se partager le
pouvoir exécutif le rappelle tout à
l'heure de la lettre de la constitution
était vraiment très intéressant parce
qu'on voit que la lettre de la
constitution dit les choses mais que le
diable est dans le détail tout de suite
on voit tout de suite ou peuvent être
les les ferments de la division on l'a
vu de manière éclatante au moment des
cohabitations quand jacques chirac et
françois mitterrand
lorsque lionel jospin et jacques chirac
participer ensemble à des sommets
européens avec le regard de nos nos
partenaires européens qui se demandaient
qui le vrai chef à ce moment là donc il
ya voilà cette espèce de couple un petit
peu infernal du premier ministre et du
et du président et en même temps et en
même temps tout repose sur ce sur ce sur
ce duo ci ont touché à cette pièce de la
vème république on toucherait vraiment
son pilier le plus essentiel son décès
de basculer vers un régime présidentiel
en supprimant le poste de premier centre
est tout un tas de conséquences
institutionnelles et jour 2.0 avec
michel rocard est pas tout à fait
pertinente parce que c'était deux
adversaires historiques de 15 20 ans au
sein du parti socialiste et que quand
mitterrand le nomme je crois que je
crois me souvenir il vit on va lever
l'hypothèque rocard il le nomme aussi
pour pour le piéger d'une certaine façon
on va tuer enfin une bonne fois pour
tout autour du fils ont le pouvoir et ne
finira par s'user et on ne changera donc
on était quand même dans un contexte
très différent depuis la mise en place
du quinquennat de toute façon on a des
premiers ministres qui ont été
réduits pour beaucoup au rang de
collaborateur et quand ils ne le sont
plus ça se passe mal
elisabeth board ont parié sur vous le
disiez c'est le tout début donc voila
mais mais son poids politique c'est un
profond
sarkozy sur sur françois fillon s'était
pas très juste à l'époque la par nicolas
sarkozy sur françois fillon fin c'est
comme ça qu'il ne consommait mais
françois fillon l'a aussi avignon une
identité politique qui était forte là on
est vraiment et encore une fois sans
mépris ni quoi que ce soit c'est juste
un
nouvelle définition du rôle le premier
ministre vraiment met en musique tout ce
que décide le président et la pratique
des manades macron depuis cinq ans
contre un une verticalité absolue que
tout se décide ce estampille se valide à
l'elysée et qu'il ya très très peu de
marge de manoeuvre pour un locataire de
matignon à moins bien sûr qu'il s'agisse
qu'il ne s'agisse d'un président nouveau
avec un mandat nouveau une nouvelle
méthode de ma commune la bbc c'est le
même on va on va l'évoqué est évidemment
et dans ce nom c'est cet équilibre
subtil du duo exécutif français ya aussi
la question de la popularité et
évidemment ça se complique quand par
exemple nicolas sarkozy alors on a pris
deux dates un pas totalement au hasard
c'est quand l'écart est important est à
36 % de popularité et françois fillon à
51% on est en avril 2012 ou quand
emmanuel macron et rats et maquereau est
à 38 et edouard philippe à 50% et là on
est en juin 2020 forcément à rien et
hamdi c'est cet équilibre là il se
complique oui mais en fait ce que vous
décrivez c'est ce qui c'est comme dans
toute relation quand il ya des jeux de
pouvoir au sein même d'une relation de
confiance et loyauté ça devient
compliqué c'est à dire que en fait au
fond le comblement de même si c'est pas
dit dans la constitution il ya le droit
et puis ya l'idée que le premier
ministre quand même politiquement
s'effacer devant donc or est-ce que vous
ne venez de dire sur la question de la
popularité c'est quand l'opinion
commence à se mobiliser en faveur de
l'un plutôt que de l'autre et c'est
alors que ils ont aussi des charges de
travail très importante et bien ça crée
et c'est vous parlez de rocard
effectivement en vérité il ya la
politique est aussi un jeu pouvoir
permanent et donc il faut effectivement
trouvé un subtil équilibre je pouvoir
entre deux grosses têtes de l'exécutif
c'est compliqué il ya un point commun
qu'il faut jamais oublier c'est que dans
les deux il y en a un qui a été élu par
un français sur deux et ça ça changerait
absolument tout ça donne vraiment c'est
quelque chose qu'on n'oublie jamais et
on peut on peut se raconter des
histoires en disant on va nous bien
mettre les choses au clair avant pas
bien regardé le programme de
gouvernement annonce des mesures les
proches du projet l'eau etc il y en a un
qui à kaka qui a été élu par un français
sur deux et qui est regardé par son
premier ministre et c'est très frappant
autour de la salle du conseil des
ministres où êtes-vous face à face et
tous les premiers ministres j'ai
interrogé sur ce sujet m me disent on
n'oublie jamais il est exactement à la
place dont on rêve dont toute la table
irait d'ailleurs c'est ce qui fait la
différence entre lui et tous les autres
vu que le président peut se débarrasser
de ça un premier ministre
qui a réussi à empêcher
françois hollande de se présenter c'est
arrivé une fois mais mais mais je
reviens sur ce qu effectivement dix
estiment jourdain dans sa chronique tout
à l'heure où nos co 13 avec ce
comparatif avec l'allemagne s'est pas
totalement anodin c'est à dire que c'est
vraiment le pouvoir absolu du présent la
république de choisir sont remises mais
si on regarde l'histoire de la vème
république il allait souvent même quand
on était pas en cohabitation il allait
souvent le chercher dans la force
politique la plus puissante de son
propre camp voyez ce que je veux dire
est ce que l'on est un peu dans ce cas
là ou pas du tout est ce que emmanuel
macron tient quand même content des
résultats des élections présidentielles
dans le choix d'elisabeth bornes n'ont
pas vraiment se trouve que effectivement
on pourra toujours dire qu'elle a une
sensibilité un peu plus sur les
questions sociales évidemment mais la
question sociale ou la sensibilité des
français à la question sociale est assez
permanentes elles ne datent pas de cette
élection
présidentielle non je pense pas du tout
que ça corresponde une volonté d'envoyer
un message aux électeurs de centre
gauche elle incarne quand même
effectivement elle n'est en politique
dans la macro ni elle incarne le premier
mandat d' emmanuel macron sera certain
nombre de réformes emblématiques des
manuels macro et elle va avoir à
conduire d'autres réformes emblématiques
au premier chef la réforme des retraites
et donc de ce point de vue là c'est vrai
que son talents de négociatrice est pape
personnalité très très très expérimenté
dans le domaine du dialogue social ça va
être un atout très important pour elle
mais je ne pense pas qu'on puisse voir
dans sa nomination un signal fort qui
est envoyé à l'électorat de gauche
ariane hamadi pardon je vous aime dit
depuis des permissions bah si c'est pas
bien donc aux médias son mea culpa je
suis vraiment désolé mais je reviens sur
l'histoire de là je reviens sur
l'histoire de la popularité
je lisais dans une dépêche afp un
portrait de jean castex tout à l'heure
qui rappelaient ceux là surprise d'un
ministre entendant jean castex dire tu
as vu je perds trois points le président
en gagne 2 je tiens mon rôle
c'était presque le bonheur absolu de
premier ministre ce genre jean castex
pour celles à la ccl top niveau pour un
pour imprécision vous pouvez pas mieux
c'est en gros mon job c'est pas d'être
populaire mon job c'est de tenir le
gouvernail mon job c'est d'être celui
qui même si on n'aime pas dit qu'il ya
les restrictions qui va être renvoyée en
france enfin en deux sur le devant de la
scène avec jérôme salomon et c'est pour
dire aux gens qu'il va falloir faire on
m'a dit hier les confinements alors que
le président se réservera des
allocutions où il dit nous sommes en
guerre ah c'est une intériorisation
accepté il n'a pas l'air d'être en
conflit donc c'est encore mieux parce
que quand on est ce que c'est bien
intériorisé de deux sons de son stack eu
justement d'effacement politique devant
le chef de l'état donc oui parfaite
ouais bon encontre et ce quel destin
pour jean castex moi je alors ça fait
peut-être que je vais me planter un but
ça fait huit jours que je parie ici
qu'il va devenir personnalité politique
préférée des français
comme souvent alors là c'est pas
compliqué parce que quand on quitte le
pouvoir d'un seul coup sa cote de
popularité à l'algérie qui rame mais
est-ce qui peut aller au sommet d'après
ou d'abord je pense qu'à aucune raison
particulière pour que jean castex ne
bénéficient pas de ce paradoxe français
on quitte le pouvoir en devient beaucoup
plus populaires compléter sa cote de
popularité a été pas mal indexée sur
celle du du chef de l'état de ce monde
très différent de dd doit d'edouard
philippe il a un profil à continuer à
jouer un rôle important je pense au
niveau à la fois de ses mandats locaux
sait-on jamais il a un profil je trouve
qu'il aura un bon profil pour revenir
dans pour venir au sénat surtout qu'il a
plutôt un bon profil de ce point de vue
là la fois sa personnalité personnalité
plutôt de consensus ses mandats locaux
son attachement à la question des
territoires oui
ce que n'a pas du tout elisabeth bande
pour le coup c'est là que jean castex il
était utile à emmanuel macron toutes les
raisons qu'on est gay mais aussi par sa
complémentarité pour un pouvoir central
qui était jugé très techno très parisien
très arrogant très hautain là avec avec
isabelle borne le côté techno alors
peut-être pas parisiennes puisqu'elle va
se faire les centres tenté de se faire
élire dans le calvados faites mais voilà
mais globalement ça renforce plutôt
l'idée de la technocratie au pouvoir que
l'idée de des territoires où la ruralité
ou de la france éternelle qu'elle est un
petit parfum un petit peu comme ça
vintage avec avec le jean castex quand
on parle des territoires ce serait
étonnant qu'on ne le voit pas emmanuel
macron ne l'utilisent pas pendant la
campagne législative ans n'a pas être
long mais mais c'est à peu près certain
que il va pas complètement se reposer
après tout de suite tout de suite je
vois pas ce que parce qu'il va être un
trop trop futile justement parce que
cette popularité va forcément un petit
peu progressé de la enfin la
personnalité préférée je vous y soyez
pas trop moi je pense qu'il
est l'heure philippe en l'occurrence est
sorti de matignon déjà très très haut et
il y avait il ya une espèce de
d'attitude de deux chambres en a
beaucoup comparé les styles et et je
sais mais sans doute reste à dire mais
il ya de ça dans le dans la popularité
évidemment donc maintenant c'est sûr que
leur demande un lido de l'amour
voilà dix ans les munichois et mes 2 mai
de lire tous les commentaires j'ai envie
d'être canonisé mois pour moi jean
castex je plaisante mais je veux dire la
csc
les ministres mais même les acteurs de
la société civile moi j'ai vu plein de
messages très très très très alléchant
alors c'est intéressant parce que rooney
ça nous a fichu en campagne pour les
élections législatives c'est dans moins
d'un mois et jean luc mélenchon ne ne
laisse aucune place à emmanuel macron
c'est à dire que il a invité les
journalistes on peut dire que la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale critique beaucoup les
journalistes depuis quelques jours mais
enfin là ils étaient très contents que
les journalistes viennent l'écouter pour
prendre la parole et commenter la
nomination d'elizabeth bornes en écoute
jean luc mélenchon cette nomination se
porte sur une femme qui a toutes les
compétences et les qualités personnelles
pour assumer la tâche qui lui a été
confié en effet elle incarnera la
continuité de la politique du président
de la république et des précédents
premiers ministres du premier
quinquennat c'est donc en quelque sorte
une nouvelle saison de maltraitance
sociale et écologique qui commence un
personnage parmi les figures les plus
durs de la maltraitance social macro
nist vos locaux 13 c'est intéressant
dans la stratégie politique jean luc
mélenchon pour l'instant il fait qu un
quasi sans faute depuis
alors je mets entre parenthèses la
sphère tabou a semé dans la stratégie
politique depuis trois semaines
et son expérience parle clairement là
comme il a réussi un sacré coup de
billard c'est à dire d'arriver à
transformer une défaite à la
présidentielle il ne qualifie pas pour
le deuxième tour en une victoire
politique aujourd'hui il a créé au fond
l'événement autour de ces élections
législatives il les a transformés en
élection à enjeu politique alors que ça
partait pour être des élections de
confirmation 3ème et 4ème tour de la
présidentielle il a planté le décor il a
donné un objectif à son temps politique
une famille de la gauche maintenant
réunica un objectif imposer une
cohabitation à emmanuel macron donc de
ce point de vue là ça restera un cas
d'école de la gestion d'une défaite à la
présidentielle et de remobilisation
instantanément sur un objectif les
législatives et c'est vraiment
intéressant parce que les élections
législatives avaient perdu un petit peu
cette dimension très d'élections très
politique qu'elle avait lorsqu'elle
était clairement déconnecté de la
présidentielle donc on verra ce qui se
passera les 12 et 19 juin mais il a
réussi son coup politique d'ores et déjà
cas d'école dit bruno cautrès rien elle
m'a dit c'est votre job de conseillers
notamment les personnalités politiques
est ce que c'est effectivement un bon
cas d'école ce qui se passe depuis trois
semaines dans le sillage de finalement
alors ça fait 7 mm il ya cinq semaines
de la défaite ce qu'il faut rappeler que
jean luc mélenchon ne ce qu'elle suffit
pas quoi on a tendance à l'oublier mais
d'une défaite d'une troisième défaite à
la présidentielle où je suis je suis je
suis tout à fait d'accord dans le sens
où ce que moi je note comme c'est le
côté hold up politique c'est à dire que
les gens avaient perdu l'habitude du
fait tout un rapport de force mise en
scène je veux dire pas souterrain et
cetera puisse vraiment la formation
trotskiste aide beaucoup en quand même
enfin je vais pas mais bon il ya quand
même des formations qui sont structurées
par le rapport de force comment
l'exacerber pour en faire après une
victoire ce qu'ils avaient beaucoup plus
disparu du champ politique parce que
c'est pas qu'il ya moins de rapport de
forces c'est juste qu'il se fait de
façon plus silencieuse et autrement et
donc c'est vrai que donc ce que je
disais en la stratégie de l'ange blanc
jean moulant 2 mettre en scène un
rapport de forces et faire ce rôle de
plat et trois enfin moi ce qui me qu'il
fait là c'est remettre le clivage en
espèce de clivage droite gauche
sur le mode de la fronde sociale et
essayer en bataille culturelle de
présenter aussi des voix du front
national c'est à dire qu'il fait
vraiment quelque chose de vraiment
intelligent je trouve politiquement en
termes stratégiques et mathieu on va
conclure sur ce tout petit chapitre
mélangeant mais c'est quand même
intéressant parce que
potentiellement on devrait consacrer une
heure et demie démission à elizabeth
bornes la stratégie d' emmanuel macron
le futur gouvernement et réussi à se
faire une petite place oui parce qu'il
veut pas laisser un pouce
à l'adversaire après il s'est
mécaniquement qu'on va moins parler de
lui vraiment parler bien sûr l'union
elle était faite parce que le programme
on le connaît alors il peut augmenter le
smic 200 euros tous les deux jours pour
essayer de refaire parler de lui mais
globalement la il sait que la tension
les projecteurs vont se braquer sur
matignon sur la composition du
gouvernement sur des profils des
ministres sur les premières mesures à
prendre et donc d'une certaine façon si
j'ose dire ça va être plus compliqué et
un peu comme s'ils avaient mangé son
pain blanc dans cette première partie de
campagne des législatives merci beaucoup
merci à tous les trois doivent
participer à ce premier débat de sens
public ariane a m'a dit merci encore une
fois est désolé écorché oui mais bon
quand même ça ça m'agace donc mea culpa
mea maximale et bérangère j'appelle le
titre de votre livre c'est le sioux
évidemment qui est publié aux éditions
de l'archipel